Here's a list then of some of the possible rational zeros that we came up with
in the last quiz. In fact this is just the positive versions. Starting at the
top of this list and then working down, please plug in each of these values of
x into the function. And oops, I made a mistake. I accidentally wrote f of x
instead of P of x. Remember it's super important to keep the names of our
functions straight so that we know what functions we're talking about, but
everyone makes mistakes including me. Once you've found the value of the
function at each of these X values please evaluate whether or not it's a zero.
If P of X does equal zero then please type O Y in the zero column, but if it
doesn't type and N. Since some of these numbers are pretty big I'm going to
make your life a little bit easier. As soon as you type a y into the zero
column, you can stop. We're just trying to find which x value is the first
zero. Or at least the first zero on this list. That will be enough information
for us to continue simplifying this function, and figuring out more information
that we need.